y
[Música]
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
acusó formalmente al expresidente donald
trump del senado por incitación a la
insurrección tras la toma del capitolio
del 6 de enero será la segunda vez que
trump se enfrente a un juicio político
el primero para un presidente que ya no
está en el cargo tenemos reportes de
washington
la comisión europea aumentó la presión
sobre astrazéneca tras quedar
insatisfecha con las explicaciones de la
farmacéutica sobre sus retrasos en la
entrega de las vacunas contra el covent
19 al tiempo que propuso endurecer las
restricciones para las áreas con mayor
incidencia del virus
la comisión de derechos humanos del
senado chileno aprobó un proyecto de ley
que busca conceder indultos a las
personas detenidas en el contexto del
estallido social iniciado en octubre de
2019 sin embargo el presidente sebastián
piñera anunció que vetará la iniciativa
en caso de aprobarse
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 se redoblan con
gusto saludarlos comenzamos este
informativo en eeuu donde la cámara de
representantes de mayoría demócrata
entregó formalmente al senado la
acusación que pesa sobre el ex
presidente de donald trump incitación a
la insurrección tras la toma el
capitolio por parte de sus seguidores el
pasado 6 de enero y donde murieron 5
personas así inicia el segundo juicio
político contra el republicano que
podría terminar con una inhabilitación
de por vida que bloquee sus futuras
aspiraciones presidenciales por su parte
el presidente del bayern no cree que
haya suficientes votos para condenar a
trump el informe de andré amaya
el futuro político de donald trump está
en manos del senado la cámara de
representantes- en el juicio entregó
formalmente la acusación por escrito
contra el exmandatario a los senadores
el único cargo del que se acusa al ex
presidente es incitar a la insurrección
durante un discurso a sus seguidores el
pasado 6 de enero antes de que cientos
de ellos asaltaron el capitolio marco
one artículo primero incitación a la
insurrección la constitución dispone que
la cámara de representantes tendrá el
poder exclusivo de acusación y el
presidente será destituido de su cargo
en caso de acusación y condena por
traición soborno u otros delitos graves
y faltas además la sección 3 de la
decimocuarta enmienda de la constitución
prohíbe a cualquier persona que abro
comillas participó en una insurrección o
rebelión contra estados unidos de ocupar
cualquier cargo en eeuu cierro comillas
android y night state web en entrevista
con la cadena de noticias cnn el
presidente joe biden aseguró que no cree
que haya suficientes votos en el senado
para condenar a la expresión
de trump en este su segundo juicio
político muchos aseguran que será muy
difícil lograr que 17 senadores
republicanos voten para condenar al
magnate el número necesario de votos y
los 50 demócratas votan por una condena
trump es el único presidente de eeuu que
ha sido acusado dos veces por la cámara
de representantes- y se convertirá en el
primero en enfrentar un juicio después
de dejar el cargo se espera que el
senado inicia el juicio el próximo 9 de
febrero en base al artículo presentado
este lunes
previamente conversamos con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense de cristóbal vázquez
quien nos comentó las consecuencias que
traerá este juicio para donald trump y
para la presidencia de bailén eso fue lo
que nos dijo
pues sin duda todo lo otro ya no puede
ser destituido así que esto se hace
sobre todo para dejar un precedente y
para evitar que en el futuro pueda
aspirar a cargos públicos lo que está
pasando es que ya hay un asesor de hecho
un asesor político de la administración
pasada que está en el congreso
presionando a los republicanos para que
no voten a favor del impeachment
amenazándolos de alguna manera con que
el presidente de trump les quite su
apoyo si éstos quieren aspirar a una
reelección en el senado en los próximos
años así que pues por parte de donald
trump si le puede afectar para la
aspiración a un cargo público pero hay
que tener en cuenta que dos tercios de
la cámara alta- dos tercios del senado
tiene que aprobar este infinitamente y
en este momento las sillas son cincuenta
para demócratas se encuentra para
republicanos así que lo hace bastante
difícil que el impeachment pues tenga
buen futuro tenga buen fruto teniendo en
cuenta que se necesitan dos tercios es
decir diecisiete republicanos casi que
tendrían que votar
a favor de este impeachment para joe
biden pues simplemente es todo un mes
todo el mes de febrero perdido porque
los senadores estarán enfocados en el
juicio político
el expresidente de eeuu donald trump
anunció la apertura de una oficina en
paunovic ciudad de florida a la que se
trasladó para recibir tras concluir su
mandato la cual será responsable de sus
declaraciones públicas la nueva oficina
será responsable también de administrar
la correspondencia las declaraciones
públicas las apariciones y las
actividades oficiales de donald trump
además de continuar con la agenda de su
administración a través del activismo
público
en noticias de la pandemia de kobe 19 en
américa latina falleció el ministro de
defensa de colombia carlos holmes
trujillo tras varios días de
complicaciones por coronavirus el
funcionario llevaba varios días
internada en el hospital militar de
bogotá la capital del país en una unidad
de cuidados intensivos donde presentaba
un cuadro crítico debido a una infección
respiratoria aguda derivada de la
neumonía viral por la pandemia la
noticia de su muerte la confirmó entre
otras personas su hermano josé renán
trujillo vía twitter a las 3 30 de la
madrugada de este 26 de enero y méxico
supere los 150 mil decesos por
coronavirus desde el inicio de la
pandemia además en las últimas 24 horas
se detectaron 8 mil 521 nuevos contagios
por lo que casi 1.8 millones de personas
se han contagiado en ese país méxico
sigue ocupando el cuarto lugar en el
mundo con más decesos debido a esta
pandemia
detrás estados unidos brasil e india- el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador quien contrajo el virus se
encuentra ahí
y con síntomas leves veamos el informe
de natalia plazas
es uno más de los 17 millones de
mexicanos contagiados
el presidente del país andrés manuel
lópez obrador dio positivo por el
coronavirus el mandatario ha sido
fuertemente criticado por la gestión que
ha hecho de la pandemia de coronavirus
en el país
desde el inicio de la emergencia
minimizó su impacto siento que no vamos
a atender problemas mayores y mientras
otros países de la región imponían
restricciones su administración se
resistía no dejen
salir todavía estamos en la primera fase
ya nosotros yo les voy a decir cuando no
salga a pesar de haber sufrido un
infarto y padecer hipertensión rara vez
se le ha visto con una mascarilla en
público a lo largo de la pandemia ha
continuado sus viajes y mítines por
diferentes puntos del país y ha seguido
saludando a sus simpatizantes con
apretones de manos y abrazos donde el
coronavirus esos de que éste no se puede
uno abrazar hay que abrazarse si no pasa
nada o sea éste
así promovió dudosos métodos para una
supuesta protección ante el contagio de
este ente
detente
ahora ambos se une a otros líderes
mundiales que han contraído la
enfermedad como el ex presidente
estadounidense donald trump el
presidente brasileño jair bolsonaro o el
primer ministro británico boris johnson
también ellos restaron importancia al
impacto del virus y se negaron al inicio
de la pandemia a imponer restricciones
el primer caso de la enfermedad se
detectó a finales de febrero en ese país
menos de un año después de asuma 150.000
muertes por corona virus méxico es la
cuarta nación a nivel mundial con mayor
número de muertes por esa enfermedad
los retrasos en las entregas de las
vacunas cobit 19 anunciados por
astrazéneca son inaceptables así lo ha
hecho saber la comisión europea la
farmacéutica británica anunció que
estaría suministrando muchas menos dosis
de las previstas pero esta semana el
bloque ha intensificado la presión para
obtener respuestas rápidas del
fabricante
indignación en bruselas después de que
astrazéneca anunciara que no podrá
entregar a europa el número de vacunas
acordado el bloque que ya se encuentra
bajo presión por su lentitud en el
proceso de vacunación ha prometido tomar
todas las medidas necesarias para
proteger a sus ciudadanos y pidió
transparencia en las exportaciones de
las farmacéuticas de opinión
la unión europea ha prefinanciado el
desarrollo de la vacuna y su producción
y quiere ver el retorno de wons sino la
unión europea quiere saber exactamente
qué dosis ha producido astrazéneca hasta
ahora y si se han entregado oa quién
reija kindler la comisión europea ha
utilizado hasta ahora dos vacunas para
contener la pandemia las de facer y las
de modernas y esperaba aprobar esta
semana las de astrazéneca para un
despliegue inmediato los países europeos
ya se han comprometido a comprar 300
millones de dosis a la empresa
sin embargo astrazéneca no es el único
fabricante de vacunas que
yo nado al bloque la semana pasada a
facer tampoco cumplió con las entregas
prometidas estos retrasos podrían hacer
más difícil que la unión europea alcance
su objetivo de vacunar al 70 por ciento
de su población adulta para el final del
verano en agosto
el virus de la desigualdad así fue
titulado el más reciente informe de la
organización oxfam que da cuenta del
aumento de la riqueza de los
multimillonarios y la pobreza en quienes
ya tenía un poco debido a esta pandemia
la organización indicó que los fenómenos
de la economía unido a la crisis
sanitaria desatada por el coronavirus ha
tenido la capacidad de incrementar la
desigualdad en casi todos los países por
igual y reducir la ventana de
oportunidades para alcanzar una
recuperación justa de acuerdo con este
informe los multimillonarios se
recuperaron del golpe económico que dejó
el cierre total de los confinamientos e
incluso aumentaron sus fortunas en sólo
nueve meses mientras que los más pobres
se les tomara casi una década retomar
las condiciones económicas previas a
esta pandemia
el sistema de naciones unidas se sumó al
generalizado el rechazo de un decreto de
ley aprobado por el parlamento de
honduras que prohíbe el aborto y el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
en el país y exhortó al poder
legislativo a reconsiderar la
ratificación de esta reforma la onu
reiteró que la reforma constitucional va
en contra de las obligaciones
internacionales en materia de derechos
humanos pues impide abordar un problema
de salud pública señaló además que la
reforma podría aumentar la situación de
desigualdad y discriminación por razones
de género en el país
[Música]
en chile una comisión del senado aprobó
un proyecto de ley para endulzar a los
más de cinco mil detenidos durante la
ola de protestas iniciada en octubre del
año 2019 sin embargo el presidente
sebastián piñera está dispuesto a vetar
la iniciativa en caso de aprobarse el
país votará el 11 de abril a los
miembros que formarán la constituyente
que redactará una nueva carta magna
reclamo de esta ola de protestas informa
lluís muñoz
las secuelas del estallido social de
chile continúan a día de hoy la comisión
de derechos humanos del senado aprobó un
proyecto de ley para indultar a los
detenidos en la ola de protestas
iniciada en octubre de 2019
durante meses cientos de personas se han
estado concentrando todos los viernes en
el centro de la capital para exigir la
libertad de los presos a pesar de las
restricciones contra el kobe 19
los familiares han recogido 5000 firmas
en una carta que pide que no se vete la
ley la iniciativa reconoce que muchas
personas cometieron actos punibles pero
alegan razones humanitarias y
excepcionales más de 5 mil personas
fueron detenidas durante el estallido de
las cuales 2.180 pasaron a prisión
preventiva el presidente sebastián
piñera está decidido a vetar la ley de
salir adelante atenta contra el orden
público la seguridad ciudadana la
democracia y el estado de derecho
el 6 de octubre de 2019 subió el precio
del pasaje del transporte público de
santiago fueron unos 4 centavos de dólar
desde ese momento empezaron unas
protestas que dejaron más de 30 muertos
centenares de mutilados oculares miles
de heridos violaciones de los derechos
humanos y detenidos
el estallido dio lugar a un referendo
constitucional que en octubre de 2020
fue aprobado por la ciudadanía el 11 de
abril serán elegidos los 155 miembros de
la constituyente que tratarán de
modernizar un país en el que rige una
carta magna heredada del dictador
augusto pinochet
pues
el primer ministro italiano giuseppe
conte le presentó este martes
oficialmente la renuncia al presidente
sergio matar el a tras la crisis de
gobierno originada por la falta de apoyo
a su coalición en el parlamento después
del abandono del partido italia viva de
matteo renzi el presidente matar el a
recibir la renuncia e iniciará consultas
con los partidos del país para buscar
una salida a esta crisis y formar así un
nuevo gobierno
los agricultores de india que protestan
desde hace dos meses contra las nuevas
leyes agrícolas del gobierno del primer
ministro narendra modi se enfrentaron
con la policía en el llamado día de la
república los manifestantes rompieron
las barricadas de la policía lo que
llevó a los agentes a utilizar gases
lacrimógenos para contener los
productores agrícolas dicen que las
nuevas leyes aprobadas en septiembre del
año 2020 generan sus medios de vida y
sólo ayudan a las grandes empresas
[Aplausos]
de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo continúa con nosotros feliz
día
[Música]
franz bético